I'm a 24 year old machinist.
I work CNC machines,
do setups in order tooling.
Most of the people I work with have worked here for over 15 years.
The owner of my company wants to make me the shop manager and honestly I'm not
too tore up about it.
I feel like the older guys who've been around won't want to take scheduling and
Mac manufacturing advice from a young guy.
I have good relationships with all the the shop guys,
but I'm worried about stepping into this role so soon.
Only been with the company for three years.
Okay.
Your boss isn't asking you to do this job if you're not ready for it.
That's,
that's number one.
And the fact that you don't think you're ready as a good sign.
I've said this before because it means that you're humble,
so you feel like that.
That's good.
That's probably one of the reasons why you're doing well and probably one of the
reasons that your boss thinks you're ready for the jobs because you're humble,
so that's good.
But you also have to remember that being humble has to be balanced.
Dichotomy of leadership with confidence and even with a little bit of
aggression.
So there's a reason that you're getting asked to do this job and the boss needs
you to step up.
Now just because you become the manager or the boss doesn't mean yet.
You have to start bossing people around,
right?
It actually means that you should remain humble,
that you should take input from them,
that you can still take advice from them as opposed to just giving them advice.
All those things are fine.
And I just kind of asked this question the other day,
a young,
uh,
construction business and a kid and we were in a big meeting with a,
with a bunch of leadership from foreman to engineers all in the same room,
bunch of great guys from a great company.
And one of the young engineers raised his hand and said,
you know,
I'm young and I am going to be in charge of these guys.
You know,
I'm not sure I'm comfortable with these guys.
Had been doing it for a lot longer.
What can I do to,
you know,
gain their respect.
And I said,
okay,
who in this room knows more than that?
Engineered back there about construction and all these salty construction
foreman's raised their hands.
And I said,
who?
You know,
who's going to think that this guy has got the best idea?
Raise your hands.
All the hands go down.
And I said,
so this is what you're dealing with buddy.
I said,
now let me ask another question to the group group.
If this kid comes in and says,
I know how to do this better than you.
Listen to me and do it my way,
who's going to have respect for him?
Raise your hand.
No hands go up.
If this young kid comes in and says,
Hey,
I'm an engineer.
I've been educated,
but I haven't been doing this for long.
Can you give me some recommendations on how we do this so we can do the best job
possible?
Who's going to have respect for them?
Everyone raises their hand.
So there you have it.
You don't have to know everything as a leader,
no one expects you to everything,
especially as a young leader.
That's okay.
And actually when you admit that you actually gained respect,
when you ask for people's input,
you actually gain.
People get the paranoid feeling that if they don't know something,
they're going to be seen as weak.
It's not true.
So
you can just step up to the physician.
Still be humble.
Still take advice.
Now,
this doesn't mean that you're a pushover,
right?
That doesn't mean that you just listen to what everyone says.
Do.
You don't make any decisions.
No.
It actually means that you show respect to their experience and when it comes
time to make a decision,
you get the best input and then you make a decision and you explained your
decision.
And if your decision is wrong,
you admit it,
and if it's not wrong,
you push forward.
So that's you need to do,
you're getting asked to be put in this position for a reason.
So do it gets them.
Seems like a common one.
Yeah,
that one.
I'm Stephanie The new role,
for sure.
Everyone asks that question.
Yeah,
man,
I answered it again.
There you go.
For everyone's benefit,
including my own,
I learn from it every time.
That's the ethos,
right?
Coleen humble.
Yeah.
Be Open minded.
Take advice.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Don't have to know everything.
Yes.
Three days ago,
uh,
our neighbor,
young girl,
one of my daughter's friends,
12 years old,
just comes over there messing around in swimming.
Uh,
she grabs my daughter's jump rope and she's jumping rope and she does the cross,
you know,
you jump up and you cross crossover crossover.
Yeah.
So she does that in man.
I used to jump rope back in the day,
but I never really could do the crossover.
Let's face it nonetheless.
So she's jump roping and jumping around and I'm like,
Hey,
do that cross the crossover thing again.
She does it.
She's doing,
you know,
she's 12 years old,
she taught,
I'm like,
Dang,
I never could do that.
And she's like,
well,
you just gotta do it like this until that.
So I'm like,
okay.
I grabbed the rope and I try and the roads do small cycle.
Grab my rope.
Yeah,
I gotta jump rope.
Oh,
well I told my daughter grab it.
So she grabs it.
And this is,
this is like a kind of like one of those pro speed ropes,
you know,
so it's like kind of,
so if I make a mistake on this rope is going to hurt.
I didn't have any shoes on.
I was barefoot.
Solon style,
Hawaiian sell for sure 100% and then so I go forward,
I'm or I can jump rope still pretty good right now.
Still I haven't done in awhile.
And she goes,
okay,
so right here at the top,
you know,
you,
you cross you,
this is where you want to cross at the top.
I try,
oh,
hits my foot painful.
And she's like,
no,
you got to do,
no.
Never showed the paint to the kids.
I try not to anyway.
So I was like,
okay,
boom,
fail.
If she could.
She was like,
no more at the top,
you know,
it'll,
it'll just whatever.
So I'm like,
okay,
I do it.
And it took me four times on my fourth time.
I did it for the first time in my life.
By the way,
the crossover with the painful speed rope.
Some,
you know,
some mental fortitude right there,
thrown in so hardcore.
I did it.
You should've seen it,
but you should've seen the look on her end,
my daughter's face.
They were like,
oh.
Like it was,
you know,
like I just got my purple belt to song nonetheless.
So boom,
what do we have right there?
The situation,
this is what I took from it too.
We have a situation,
a full grown athletic,
arguably person learning to do something that's really not that easy.
Obviously,
if I've never done it in my life,
learning to do something that takes a fair amount of skill from a 12 year old
girl in real time.
And you know what I did
to boot and gave her the credit.
I said,
Dang,
you are the the best teacher.
Yes,
exactly right.
So that's the thing.
You're still home.
The moral of your story,
which was a long story.
Yeah.
Be Humble.
You can learn from anybody.
Yes.
And when you do learn from someone,
give them the credit.
Boom.
That's what I did.
See,
I said that in 13 seconds.
I know brow,
but I'm just saying it was impactful and it reminded me of that story.